avant monsieur giscard d'estaing je vais
vous dire que hier soir et cette nuit au
cours de notre édition spéciale
élections et au cours de tables rondes
ininterrompue vous avez pu entendre de
nombreuses personnalités politiques en
particulier messieurs jean-jacques
servan-schreiber et le canut et
plusieurs ministres comme monsieur edgar
faure fontanet boula et le cas des
leaders de formations politiques comme
messieurs poniatowski et peyrefitte est
aussi monsieur marché qui a fait une
déclaration la plupart de ses
interventions vous les avez à nouveau
entendue ce matin au cours de notre
émission spéciale de 7h à 9h et vous les
avez également réentendu au cours de
votre journal de 13 heures aussi ce soir
je vous propose d'écouter de nouvelles
réactions ainsi monsieur michel debré
qui ne s'était pas encore exprimé
monsieur poniatowski et astier marchés
qui ont reçu à nouveau cet après midi
nos équipes de reporters alors nous
allons d'abord écouter monsieur marché
le secrétaire général du parti
communiste qui a fait une nouvelle
déclaration en fin d'après midi monsieur
marché
monsieur georges marchais vous dites que
le résultat des élections est un échec
pour la majorité
est ce que ce n'est pas aussi un échec
pour la gauche car au parlement vous
êtes assez loin d'inquiéter la majorité
je rappelle que l'air la majorité vit sa
politique que condamner par 60% des
français au premier tour
et au deuxième tour la gauche fait
encore plus de voix que la majorité n'en
fait par conséquent oui c'est un échec
pour la majorité qui ne doit de
conserver une majorité d'élus au
parlement qu' grâce au ralliement
inconditionnels de monsieur lecanu et
pour ce qui concerne la gauche c'est
différent
nous n'avons eu que peu de temps pour
faire connaître le programme commun pour
renforcer l'union réalisé autour du
programme commun à travers tout le pays
et il faut pas oublier que la majorité a
utilisé tous les moyens pour falsifier
caricaturer le programme comme que dans
ces conditions 10 millions d'hommes et
de femmes aient voté pour ce programme
nous disons que c'est un succès alors il
est évident que il va nous falloir
maintenant poursuivre nos efforts pour
ce qui concerne le parti commune east le
résultat des élections ne saurait en
quoi que ce soit modifié sa stratégie
précisément que va-t-il se passer
maintenant au cours de la campagne vous
avez dit le programme commun est un bébé
qui ne demande qu'à grandir mais comment
va-t-il grandir il n'est pas piqué mais
pourrait le faire d'abord premièrement
il ya les questions qui vont se poser
tout de suite pour les travailleurs et
des masses populaires
les travaille à limaces ou pierre mondy
revendications des exigences la majorité
a fait des promesses ou qu'on a campagne
électorale je suis convaincu que les
travailleurs masse populaire demandant
que c'est une promesse soit et nous nous
serons aux côtés des grands ailleurs
dans leurs actions et nous poursuivrons
nos efforts pour expliquer expliquer
expliquer toujours le contenu même du
programme commun c'est-à-dire les
réformes profondes qui sont nécessaires
à ce pays pour résoudre les grands
problèmes qui sont posés
lorsque vous dites qu'il va y avoir des
revendications a satisfait après
voyez-vous une vague d'agitation sociale
je ne prévois rien ce sont les
travailleurs qui décideront seulement
d'ores et déjà les travailleurs ils
demandent qui est pas salaire inférieur
à 1000 font les travailleurs demandent
qui est l'augmentation de sallèles
demande que l'ajout donnant droit à la
retraite soit avancé à 60 ans pour les
hommes 55 ans pour les femmes sont des
idées revendications déjà qui sont
posées et nous sommes bien convaincu
nous que le gouvernement va poursuivre
la politique qui a toujours été la
sienne ce pouvoir et de représentants
des grands monopoly ne peut pas faire
une autre politique